coureur chamlou avocat franco iranien
avec nous bonjour courage chamoux merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france alors on l'a vu le chef de la
diplomatie américaine mike pompéo a
prévenu avec les états unis ferait tout
pour que les sanctions de l'onu contre
l'iran soit renouvelée et concrètement
quel est le but de ces sanctions contre
l'iran bonjour merci de m'avoir invité
bon les beats de seissan sur ces deux
nouvelles sanctions parmi d'autres
sanctions depuis des années le but en
fait de l'administration américaine
c'est d'amener de force les iraniens à
renégocier un nouvel accord de paix avec
donald trump cette fois ci pas ce dont
un train venu montrer au monde entier
que il a remis en question l'accord
signé par la précédente administration
l'administration obama
et il veut dire c'est lui qui a ramené
l'iran autour de la table et il veut pas
en fait ce qu'il dit qu'il ne veut pas
changer d'origine mais il veut juste de
nouvel accord dans l'intérêt américain
alors on l'a vu ali khamenei a une
nouvelle fois écarté toutes éventuelles
négociations avec les états unis car
selon lui c'est une opportunité pour
donald trump qui est en campagne pour
l'élection présidentielle concrètement
l'économie est ce qu'il ralliait né ce
qu'elle peut survivre puisque des deux
côtés il n'y a aucune communication
alors l'économie iranienne est en train
de s'effondrer de plus en plus chaque
jour
malheureusement les pris fin et les prix
font tous les jours pour vous donner un
exemple les prix de l'immobilier ont
augmenté de o se sont multipliées par
trois en trois mois les loyers se sont
multipliées par deux l'économie est en
train de s'effondrer
mais l'économie iranienne va pouvoir
tenir et les iraniens jouent la carte
des élections américaines en disant que
le 3 le 3 novembre qui va arriver
il y aura une nouvelle administration il
y aura un nouveau président américain en
l'occurrence il parie sur jordan qui
était l'ancien vice-président de barack
obama et qui était et qui était un des
signataires de l'accord nucléaire avec
l'iran et l'iran joue sept cas essayer
de tenir essayé de tenir l'économie
jusqu'aux 3 devant 3 9 ans pour voir si
la
ministration américaine va changer ou
pas mais malheureusement de l'état deux
pays et devient de plus en plus
catastrophique comme je vous ai dit les
prix augmentent le chômage augmente tous
les jours et les jeunes qui sont tous
très éduquée n'ont pratiquement plus
d'avenir mais ils peuvent pas aller dans
les rues pas cécile sortant là dans la
rue pour manifester bas et très souvent
taper dessus et à la rigueur il peut
même mourir la chine et la russie
pourraient avoir recours à leur droit de
veto contre la résolution américaine si
blanc justement la vente d'armes à ce
que cela pourrait créer des tensions
finalement entre les alliés ça ne pourra
pas connaître de tension en fait c'est
que avec arisem nouvelles sanctions est
en fait toutes ces politiques de
pression maximale les etats unis sont en
train de pousser l'iran de plus en plus
dans les bras chinois et russe vous
savez lire on vient de renouveler un
contrat de 20 ans un contrat militaire
de 20 ans avec la russie et ils vont
prochainement signer un accord secret on
connaît pas encore exactement tous les
temps de cet accord à un accord de 25
ans avec la chine ou la chine va
investir près de 400 milliards de
dollars dans l'économie iranienne et
l'iran en contrepartie va exporter son
pétrole vers la chine avec un prix 30 à
40% moins cher que le prix du marché
donc même si elle a réussi où les
américains ou les chinois mettent leur
veto ça ne va pas changer grand chose
puisque l'iran c'est que l'europe ne
peux pas l'aider
l'amérique a mis en place une politique
de pression maximale et l'iran sur saône
à se retourner va tomber dans les
chinois et russes obligatoires justement
ali khamenei a accusé les états
européens de n'avoir rien fait ma
question est comment se positionne
l'union européenne face à ces actions
commerciales et notamment aussi face à
ces sanctions là bas écoutez l'union
européenne pour l'instant n'a rien fait
l'union européenne a mis en place un
système qu'on appelle ni sexe pour que
les entreprises européennes puissent
continuer à commercer avec l'iran mais
malheureusement à ce jour l'istec n'a
pas encore
été activé il n'est aucune opération
commerciale avec avec l'iran depuis
l'europe et l'europe qu'on le vo par
l'euro se positionne sur la politique
américaine puisque l'europe ne peut pas
contredire les américano en europe
l'europe n'a pas la force politique ni
le courage politique de s'opposer aux
américains puisqu'elle les intérêts
européens se trouvent plus aux états
unis qu'en iran et donc l'europe ne va
pas tout remettre en cause
juste pour avoir pour pouvoir faire du
commercial équilibrant des c'est pour ça
que les iraniens ne comptent plus
tellement sur les européens et compte
maintenant de plus en plus
malheureusement sur les chinois et les
russes
merci kourosh amont pour toutes ces
précisions je rappelle que vous êtes
franco iranien